بعد ضجه الغاء علامه توثيق الزرقاء عن
الحسابات الشهيره في منصه تويتر تفاجا بعض
المشاهير بعوده العلامه الزرقاء دون دفع
اي رسوم شهريه ودون تفسير ومن بين النجوم
العرب الذين عادت العلامه الزرقاء لحسابهم
عبر دياب وتامر حسني واليسا ونادين جيم
ومحمد هنيدي وحسين الجسمي ونجوى كرم وكرر
سماحه وهيفاء وهبي ورغب علامه ونوال
الزغبي ومنه شلبي وراشد الماجد وشيرين
وانغام وصابر الرباعي وغيرهم فيما بقيت
اسماء اخرى من دون توثيق فما السبب
الاجابه مع الخبير التقني عبد الله السبع
طبعا انه اي شخص لم يشترك في تويتر بلو ما
راح يكون عنده شعار التوثيق نهائيا لكن
بعدها صار شيء طلع العديد من المؤثرين حول
العالم تكلموا ان هذا الموضوع جدا سيء
لانهم ما راح يشتركون في تويتر عشان
يحصلون علامه لذلك بعض الناس رجعت لهم
علامات التوثيق مثل محمد هنيدي وايضا بعض
الممثلين العالميين والجهات الحكوميه
رجعتهم علامات التوثيق بشكل كامل بعد 24
ساعه طبعا الام ماسك هدفه من هذا الموضوع
ان الناس تدفع فلوس للحصول علامه التوثيق
حتى يحقق ارباح تويتر زي ما انتم عارفين
تويتر كانت شركه خسرانه وحصلت على مشاكل
جدا كبيره فيها لكن بسبب فطر بلو العديد
من الامور الثانيه بدات ترجع تويتر
لتحقيق علامات ايجابيه او دخل ايجابي
عندهم طبعا ايضا الشركه قالت انه اي شخص
حاليا مشترك في تويتر بلوم راح يحصل على
ظهور اعلى في منصات التواصل الاجتماعيه
عكس البقيه لذلك اذا انت ما انت مشترك في
تويتر بلو راح يكون ظهور تغريداتك او
اقتراح تغريداتك في المستخدمين اقل من
الناس اللي تشترك في تويتر
الملياردير الامريكي الى الماسك كان اعلن
سابقا موعد 20 من ابريل جاري لازالته
علامات التوثيق المجانيه من حسابات
المستخدمين في جميع انحاء العالم طالبا
دفع مبلغ 8 دولارات مقابل تلك الخدمه
المنصه الشهيره شهدت منذ بدء تطبيق هذا
القرار حاله من الفوضى بعد ان انتحلت عده
حسابات صفات حسابات اخرى ووفقها مقابل
الدفع وهذه ليست المشكله الوحيده اذ يبدو
ان تويتر سيصبح بدون رقابه فما راي عبد
الله السبع الان راح يكون في حريه تعبير
اكبر عند المستخدمين فلذلك في السابق اني
سويته مخالفه في تويتر راح يتم اغلاق
حسابك بشكل كامل لكن الان وش راح يصير راح
يصير شيء اخر انه لو سويته مخالفه فقط
التغريد اللي عليها مخالفه هي اللي راح
يتم تقييد وصوله للناس لكن حسابك راح يكون
ظاهر عند البقيه
[موسيقى]